Let’s get one thing clear.
As much as it is fun to go through the various
articles on the SCP Archive, we should take
a moment to acknowledge that it’s all fun
and games.
The SCP Foundation, all the entities and objects,
creatures and people, places and stories related
to them are just that: stories.
Fiction created by the authors of an online
wiki website.
It’s all designed to be a bit of harmless
entertainment.
But what if it isn’t harmless?
What if the characters within the world of
the SCP Archive somehow knew they had been
created by the SCP Wiki authors?
What would happen if fiction was aware that
it was, in fact, fictional?
Ask yourself, would you want to know if your
world, your life, everything you had ever
seen or known was all just a fantasy?
If the answer is no, then you need to stop
watching this video right now, but we’ll
warn you, just because you don’t know about
something, doesn’t necessarily stop it from
being true.
Still want to find out what’s going on?
Good, then you need to hear about SCP-001.
First things first, which of the various SCP-001s
are we talking about?
Anyone looking for the earliest SCP will quickly
discover that there are many different entities
and anomalies that share that number.
There are a few, in-universe reasons for this.
One is that all these anomalies were discovered
in the earliest days of the SCP Foundation,
before their current numbering system was
introduced.
Then there’s the other theories.
For example, some have speculated that the
existence of many different SCP-001s is an
intentional misdirection by the Foundation,
their way of keeping the nature of the true
first SCP a closely-guarded secret.
Regardless of what the reason is, the SCP-001
we’re looking at today is also known as
“The Database.”
Any and all information about The Database
is kept a secret from the entire SCP Foundation
apart from the Overseer Council.
And why is it such a secret?
Well, that’s because SCP-001 contains details
of the very nature of the Foundation itself,
including its creation.
But we don’t mean when and how the organization
was founded, or its history.
We mean how it was created, and by whom, in
our reality.
Confused?
Well, allow us to explain it.
At first, the file for SCP-001 describes a
group of humanoid entities that have an ability
to influence reality.
All sounds like pretty standard, bread and
butter stuff for the SCP Foundation, right?
WRONG.
These entities are, in actual fact, the authors
of the SCP Wiki themselves.
As in, the people in the real world.
The reality of the SCP Foundation is constantly
changed by these writers; written and rewritten
whenever someone edits an article on the SCP
Wiki.
That’s all fine and harmless for us, but
the Wiki authors’ impact on their world
is a cause of grave concern for the Foundation.
As we mentioned at the start, we all know
that the SCP Foundation and it’s vast catalogue
of user-generated articles on the creative
and the creepy are nothing more than a source
of fictional online entertainment.
It can be fun to study the lore and the nuances
of the different SCPs.
It can be enjoyable appreciating the creativity
and hard work that the authors put into writing
them.
In the case of fan fiction, independent stories,
original SCPs, or even animated videos dedicated
to explaining them, it can even inspire and
fuel our own written endeavors.
But, at the end of the day, when all is said
and done, we all know that the SCP Foundation
is purely fictional.
What we don’t realize is that the Foundation
knows it too.
Containing several pieces of information from
within their own archive, The Database contains
everything the Foundation knows about our
real world.
This includes everything about the real authors
of the SCP Wiki.
And you thought Deadpool was meta.
You see, because the SCP Wiki has articles
from numerous different creative writers,
chances are, the details of every new article
might not always line up with every previous
one.
For a long time, there has been much discussion
amongst devoted SCP fans regarding the “canon”
of the website.
Now, we don’t mean a big gun that launches
metal balls.
When we say canon, we mean all of the events
and stories that are considered to be an official
part of the on-going story of the SCP Foundation.
Still with us so far?
Because there are so many writers and articles
on the Wiki, the canon of the SCP Archive
is a bit inconsistent, to say the least.
And that’s fine for us, because we know
none of it is real.
It doesn’t have to all line up, just as
long as a good story is being told.
But these inconsistencies; all the little
cracks of discrepancy and disparity; are what
made the Foundation themselves realize that
they are truly living in a fiction.
In other words, SCP-001 is the SCP Foundation’s
window through what we would experience as
the fourth wall.
The fourth wall is the metaphorical barrier
that separates what we know to be real, from
what we know to be purely fiction.
In other words, it’s the line between the
audience and the fiction that they are watching,
the edge of the stage or the glass of the
television screen.
And the SCP Foundation is staring through
that fourth wall, looking out at you and me.
That’s right, it isn’t just the authors
that the Foundation are aware of, it’s all
of us.
According to their own researchers, the Foundation
has determined that we, the audience and the
writers, exist in something known as the Alpha
Layer.
What on Earth is an Alpha Layer?
Well, imagine our reality, the world and the
universe as we know it, is a slice of bread.
It’s a strange analogy, we know, but stick
with us.
Now, picture the fictional world of the SCP
Foundation as another slice of bread underneath
ours.
In-between the two can be whatever you like,
but the point isn’t that the world is a
sandwich.
The point is, that we exist on a layer of
reality above that of the SCP Wiki, and the
filling is just what keeps reality and fiction
separate.
So, as we mentioned, the Foundation is aware
of any writers and readers of the SCP Wiki,
and this does include you.
But the Wiki authors are the primary focus
of The Database.
After all, it’s the writers who are responsible
for creating the fictional world that the
SCP Foundation exists in.
Anything that forms a part of the narrative
of that world, every article, every tale,
every new SCP that gets published, even parts
of the Wiki that get taken down or rewritten
all have an impact on the Foundation’s universe.
When authors link their new SCPs to pre-existing
ones, or create connections to a Group of
Interest like the Church of the Broken God
or the Global Occult Coalition, their writing
ends up making even more of a substantial
development to the overall narrative.
And all of it ends up in The Database.
The readers of the SCP Wiki, on the other
hand, are a smaller part of SCP-001.
Mainly because they do not write or publish
the content found on the website itself.
Anything that is not specifically set in stone
by a Wiki author, can be interpreted in various
ways by a reader.
A reader’s interpretation is a powerful
concept, and should not be underestimated.
Interpretation is the difference between reading
Animal Farm as a story about a group of animals
rebelling against their human farmer, and
understanding it as a satirical and political
allegory for the events leading up to the
Russian Revolution.
So what does interpretation have to do with
SCP-001?
The point we are getting at is that any unwritten
detail or anything that isn’t explicitly
stated by a Wiki author, can be changed by
a reader’s own imagination.
This can be anything, from the appearance
or personality of an SCP or character, to
a detail about the world of the Foundation.
And in the same vein, if something in one
SCP article contradicts something written
in another, the reader is free to choose which
of them they accept as part of the universe’s
true canon.
Each reader of the SCP Wiki has their own
understanding of the material written there,
and inevitably comprehends their own version
of the events within.
And this is something that the SCP Foundation,
even in their world of fiction, is aware of
- or more specifically, the O5 Council is
aware of.
You see, the secretive overseers are the only
ones with any knowledge of SCP-001.
Only they can access The Database, only they
know the truth.
The fact that they exist in this fictional
capacity is something the Overseer Council
hopes to hide from the rest of the Foundation’s
personnel.
In an effort to keep the rest of their staff
from asking too many questions, the Council
has told them that there is currently no way
in existence that they could possibly contain
SCP-001.
But, to reassure personnel, the O5s have also
stated that this does not pose any risk, nor
would it lead to the total and utter destruction
of their observable, fictional universe.
Instead, the Council aims to focus on what
they can control, by containing any and all
information about SCP-001.
Nothing about The Database, or the truth that
it contains, is to ever leave O5 Command under
any circumstance whatsoever.
All of the information about SCP-001, or what
it contains, is kept in an
encrypted, highly-classified
form, at an unknown location.
The key needed to decrypt this data is a pass
code split into three parts.
This key is then memorized by members of the
O5 Council, each memorizing a different portion
of the pass code.
It can only be accessed if every member of
the Council unanimously agrees that it is
absolutely necessary.
And even when they do decrypt the information
about SCP-001, it remains for the eyes of
O5 Command, and strictly their eyes only.
Any member of the SCP Foundation caught leaking
data about SCP-001 is to be contained by any
means necessary.
This also includes if a member of personnel
attempts to get this classified information
out via espionage, psychic leakage, or other
devious methods.
Foundation researchers are even banned from
conducting any of their own investigations
into the nature of SCP-001, or the data it
contains.
If a lower level staff member was to somehow
find out the truth, that the entire Foundation
is just a fiction, then that person would
be at the mercy of the most senior figure
on the O5 Council.
It would be up to that senior figure to decide
the staff member’s fate.
Anyone with high enough clearance or status
within the Foundation who found out about
SCP-001, would alternatively be given a Class
A amnestic.
These are memory altering drugs that the SCP
Foundation uses to keep information about
anomalies a secret.
Apparently, even from its own staff.
Still, having your mind wiped has got to be
better than being killed or contained, just
for realizing you’re a fictional character
on an online wiki.
The O5 Council have plans in mind for us,
and for the SCP Wiki writers responsible for
creating them.
The SCP Wiki entry on The Database closes
with a proposal; a way that the O5 Council
can reach out of their fiction, directly to
the wiki’s authors in the real world.
From there?
Their goal is simple: through memetic kill
agents, the SCP Foundation will put the Wiki
authors to sleep and then kill them.
Sounds pretty far-fetched, doesn’t it?
After all, when was the last time something
fictional killed someone in our real world?
Even more bizarre, what if this kill agent
already exists?
The O5 Council must have known for a while
that their world is fictional, so they’ve
had plenty of time to develop a kill agent,
some way of reaching us and the SCP Wiki authors
in the real world.
Worse still, what if this kill agent is already
out there somewhere, lurking on the SCP Archive,
just waiting for you to find it?
And if you read it, how would it kill you?
If you don’t want to know, then that’s
your choice to make.
But if curiosity is getting the better of
you, then remember this: Beware SCP-5999.
To continue the story, go check out “The
Last SCP - SCP-5999 - This is Where I Died”,
and for more information on SCP-001, go check
out “SCP-001 - Which is the Real 001?”